sperate circuisce oggi sono con lo
sapevo che dovevi fa qualcosa di strano
va bene siamo su fort night e massima
entra non sanno chi sei potreste anche
mio nonno
ok era meglio se fosse stato mio nonno
oggi siamo già una hit siamo io pietro
che sta qua col computer di fianco e
insieme a noi ci sta pure ciccio gamer
che sa giocare a fort nate noi facciamo
schifo
e allora per bilanciare la cosa del
siccome non vinciamo mai occupa il
silicone no no tu fai schifo ai partiti
forse si giocano in quattro mini noi
giocheremo in te siamo già svantaggiati
però cc abbastanza forte quindi forse
poi anch'io
ecco non lui va nemmeno uno quindi siamo
va beh partiamo rientrati nel magazzino
un ufficio questo quanto detto a io vado
dove si lancia ciccio che aiutati ok
seguiamo le persone che sanno giocare
che noi io sono tutti siano un problema
di comunicazione iniziale mi piace mai
il paracadute però pro coppie
omosessuali ci piace questo para cause
ma che sta stage a carina ma ha sì
dobbiamo giocare dobbiamo uccidere le
persone qua
ma cos'è sta roba le sto propose
quest'arma amica di minuto bene
divertiti
grazie granda fumogena andiamo avanti
non sfasciamo dare un po almeno una
doppia vincere poi solo torto
effettivamente la vuoi smettere di
tirare fumo c'e nella mia stanza magagna
non vedo neanche la porta dai che
passerà prego prego ci nora che non vedo
niente non è possibile
dove questa uscita arrivo ciccio noti
giura non ti so spiegare cosa è successo
a me a fare un passetto c'è un tizio sul
cespuglio faccio io faccio io faccio io
no è andato dietro ai cinque gizio c'è
un cespuglio bruttissimo l'ha buttato
giù dimmi una cosa dirmi se tu sei mai
riuscito visto che i tuoi cantore di
gioco e far salire la palla sopra
noi abbiamo un ad ogni volta che
portiamo la sua città abbiamo una
tradizione che cerca di far salire una
falla sulla collina ma il problema non
la puoi calciare ti spiego che se tu sia
un p sopra la calza veramente si prova e
non lo sapevamo
aspetta che non esco con k line da
napoli bari sopra non riescono a farlo
uscire
non riesco a un mostro non riesco a
farlo uscire
non riesco a fare è bravo mezzo fa ma
dagli aiuti non lo sapevamo sta roba lì
è un milioncino per questo li vale se
vinciamo la partita tenendo un altro
guarda porca vacca marini vuoi fare
tantissimo esaltata niente e vara che è
difficilissimo fare si può fare mai come
supermario vai la bellezza una palleggio
as è riuscito 600 simili è riuscita al
primo team è bravo ce l'abbiamo fatta
appunto della giunta sai quanti episodi
per fare sta roba non ci siamo mai
riusciti c'era questa la difficoltà di
sto gioco non arriva primi chissenefrega
adesso arriveremo l'ortana arriveremo
primi con la palla è solo la palla per
arriva prima per quanto non sistema
bravo e mondana via la palla
usain bolt la palla mi sa che gli abili
amministrativo la palla stessa pa rambo
io l'ho ucciso croazia bravo pietro non
ci voleva cristo che sono utili buona
per far saltare a ballare così perché mi
sono detto beh io mi sparano da dietro
dove siamo arrivati noi fermo ci stanno
sparando
spero confermo all'aspetto ai vedo se
esce cattivissimo pappagallo colpito
forte la nostra destra sono due ma dai
ho scolpito lo so come ho fatto che la
cosa buona il segreto per una volta
nella vita che parte da che parte sempre
285 strambo l'hack è male a yara hanno
ucciso chi è che mi hanno fatto
esplodere o mano tirato una foto
incredibile ragazzi
e anche meno non ci credo save the
situation bravissimo tutti morti gli
amici emanuela mazza un'amazzone amato
ammazzano a casa ammazzo tutti mortali
non possono che cazzo ammazzo
ma stai zitto ma colta invitata a
valutare quest'altra ragazzo io la dico
vai
purtroppo per i altresì abbiamo
pochissimo tempo veramente pochissimo
pronti a sapere quando ve lo dico io ok
esaltate ma che è sta roba è un due tre
stella amenta meramente 12 preso a fare
ma questa nota non bloccarmi cos'è sta
roba ci scusami ci stanno spara e lo
sapevo che ce inculano ma se distruggono
la base vediamo prima kayak e male aia
che mai ha dietro i no ai regali e 3 no
ai ragazzi gli etero e sparano ciccio
grazie ciccio prete cosi piace sarà
facile fare l'ho già vista su scena e
sobri ma perché resta prima pietro ma
chi ha insegnato a giocarci il primo
posto
stai arrestati uno sbagliato dietro il
tiramisù dai siamo 3 contro 3 nega
affatto tutto ciccio ha fatto però se
fosse racconto drago va bene quindi come
vieni con me e l'ho colpito una cosa mi
ha presentato sultan di mezzo la lascia
lascia tanto lascio molto volentieri
senza farlo a ripetere
allora emiliano a mano per farsi è stato
per questo andare sotto no una quasi
morto è morto dai a chiamare a sinistra
piace la sinistra qua ma dai a sinistra
e la destra non sa darmi le indicazioni
mio dio ci sta a fare i casini allora
contro uno contro uno vede il rumore mi
dispiace non fanno fuori tutti
io sono qui chiudo ma che male
guarda mai sono piquet striscio ciccio
guardami sono stato utile bravi
ha fatto tutto quanto pietro bravo il
grande e grave stato sei stata una
persona utile che ha fatto la differenza
in questa partita bene dall'altra ci si
vede vai vai vai anche perché ti devo
dire la sincera verità se non mi era
parti dalla registrazione qua o te lo
giuro quella c'è sempre una vegetazione
comunque io in genere sul mio canale
registro fornendomi comai una partita
abbiamo fatto insieme abbiamo vinto
quindi fortunatamente porterà un
contenuto decente per una volta di forza
è esatto niente ma sti cazzi ma figurati
se per una volta funziona però arrivo io
picchiarlo arrivo avevo anch'io e
vecchio amico
giorgia orgia forgia marien la potenza
degli iscritti
ok perfetto mamma mia
madonna che ansia andate sotto lutate
conoscevi al forziere e mica scemo i
ragazzi viale come siete messi armi tipo
fu chi era
eccolo qua eccolo qua lo ammazzo al
marmo socio che sta volando notte no no
grazie
un morto c'è stato nella media sono ok
perfetto perfetto però spesso lei la
stidda la precisione che prego per una
volta sono stato fondamentale in più di
me la partita prima fatto cagare
io non ho visto niente tamini galla
prendo io grazie pianisti
eccoli e sentiti più che altro un
livello diverso di vederlo
no non li vedo scherzavo stanno sparando
sono fermo primo momento no per il
momento non sparate sul tetto andato
all'altra parte
ultimo
è sceso che lo vedo da qua ok visto una
pace ancora ma c'è ancora gente dove sei
tu ci hai quindi mi giro verso di te
perché c'è gente lo guarda a sinistra
no no stanno qua davanti a mente ok dai
ragazzi semina eccolo lì porca vacca
eccola la aspetta bedetti e granate
dove i ragazzi non lo vedo sono sorti a
perché vediamo
eccoli i titoli potuti la sinistra
facciamoci due si fa il giro salito a
sinistra
occhio che però fa un'incursione resta
qua a destra rega è bravo ciccio esatto
io li vedo ragazzi è capito lo so io no
non è vero scherzava spesso questi anni
ammazzato brava era l'ultimo c'è meno
resta fa ciccio tu porca vacca che se
dietro
non ci sono io sono forte a questo gioco
zitti che va in pietro e allora che
facciamo allora che facciamo è stato me
l'hai detto pure tu hai realizzato che
lo sbaglio hai realizzato cosa stavo per
fare ci sparano ci sparano ci prova
anche male ok
chi è che ci sparava maledetti pezzi e
sterco
ma dove davanti a forse forse da così in
fondo ma non ne sono sicuro
sono rimasti in otto allora si fosse
brava a sparare certo che puoi provare
ho colpito uno ha colpito di nuovo
tensione sono stati letali
basta sparare basta sparate dobbiamo
andare da noi abbiamo fatto un male cane
ragazzi ed ai meno male gli iphone e noi
abbiamo abbiamo gli abbiamo fatto ha
detto che abbiamo detto già fatto 100
mega barile siamo 3 15 se cose non ci si
può che male alle visto io ragazzi a che
male che il dolore forte madonna rega
che schifo sono giocati bravo va bene
altre partite su vittorie su partite due
vittorie c'era è incredibile ho fatto di
nuovo nakheel anch'io e quante fateci ha
da sempre bosca cosa è successo mamma
mia
per i ragazzi questa rapina di forte
knight spero vi sia piaciuto pietro
grazie pietro
grazie della tua utilità e anche della
mia mente
chissà quanto migliore però grazie a dio
c'era texter d'altra parte comunque
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
vi piace molto mi piace anche bisogno di
un insuccesso che si chiede il conto e
ci vediamo
non puoi chiudere il vino tanto dal
comando io devo cambiare amico bella
ragazzi beh sì ma devi stuprarmi il tele
il dell'it e le fonsai capaci a parlare
[Musica]